as you are probably aware many Game of
Thrones fans are obsessed how the show
ended after nearly a decade on
television and following seven largely
fantastic seasons the acclaimed fantasy
drama delivered a controversial swan
song a season that many viewers thought
was rushed and satisfying and really
something of a mess contention over the
final season came to a head when one
upset fan wrote a petition demanding
that HBO we make all six episodes with
brand-new writers for some fans it's
hard not to roll your eyes the petition
reads in parts David Benioff and DB
Weiss have proven themselves to be
woefully incompetent writers more than
1.7 million disgruntled Game of Thrones
fans assigned the petition but those
efforts were reportedly made in vain
basically if you think the network is
planning to remake the season and we've
got news for you according to
Entertainment Weekly HBO President of
Programming Casey ploys address e online
petition drawing the Television Critics
Association summer press tour there are
very few downsides to having a hugely
popular show while I can think of when
you try to end it many people have
opinions on how to end it I think that
come to the territory the petition shows
a lot of enthusiasm and passion for the
show but it wasn't something we
seriously considered I can't imagine
another network would Lloyd's also
mentioned that HBO really doesn't have
too much creative control when it comes
to a hit show like Game of Thrones in
regards to the final Caesar and he said
there is a rhythm between show runners
and network a minimal back and forth
here and there that's not just G ot
Silicon Valley is doing their final
season they have a really good handle on
what the show is and what the end will
look like it's not like we are all over
them as for Game of Thrones it sounds
like blaze wasn't terribly surprised but
a negative reaction after the final
episode aired back in May he told
variety I think to a certain extent that
was expected that first show this big
there's no way you're going to please
everybody
I think Benioff and Weiss landed a
massive plane ended a great job doing it
but you're never going to make everybody
happy nor should that be the goal
meanwhile some former Game of Thrones
cast members were evidently quite
displeased about the petition sophie
Turner the actress who played Sansa
Stark found it particularly upsetting
telling the New York Times people always
have an idea in their heads of how they
want a show to finish and so when it
doesn't go to their liking they start to
speak up about it and rebell all of
these petitions and things like that
I think it's disrespectful to the crew
and the writers and the
makers who have worked tirelessly over
ten years and for eleven months shooting
the last season
Isaac Hempstead right who portrayed bran
stark told The Hollywood Reporter I saw
today there's a petition to redo the
ending it's just absurd I can't even
fathom it it's just ridiculous it's
ridiculous that people think they can
just demand a different ending because
they don't like it
John Stehr actor Kit Harington didn't
mince words when asked about the
petition telling Esquire I don't mean to
sound mean about critics here but
whatever critic spends half an hour
writing about this season and makes
their negative judgment on it in my head
if they can go themselves in the end no
one's bigger fans of the show than we
are and we're kind of doing it for
ourselves that's all we could do really
and I was just happy we got to the end
clearly the folks at HBO realized that
no matter what you put out there there's
just no pleasing everyone at the end of
the day some audience members will
always react with shock and dismay check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]